you can see the sun is setting here
officially at 7 31 pm showing you an
assistant coach for the celtics pointing
to their watch probably indicating that
very thing kyrie irving going to the
back now we all know that he has fasted
in the past he has said publicly he had
to wait till sunset before he could in
take any food or liquid and as we just
told you sunset just passed i spoke with
an athlete who has played during ramadan
while he was observing and he told me
that when he played games and the sunset
happened during the game he would in
fact go and get something to eat
immediately something small in light
high in sugar normally fruit like grapes
or oranges to give him a quick injection
of energy because you guys it's been 13
hours and 36 minutes since sunrise and
sunset if he is fasting that entire time
no food no liquid and that includes
water let's get into uh you talk also
about about uh kyrie irving the famous
basketball player kyrie on a personal
note you have said that you are fasting
for ramadan which for those who are
unaware means no food no water from sun
up to sun down
how do you muster the energy to go out
and score 34 points with very little
nutrition in your body
well it's a journey with god and i'm not
alone in this i have brothers and
sisters all around the world that are
fasting with me
uh we we hold our prayers and our
meditations very sacred what do you
think when you see someone like that a
lot he talks about fighting for freedom
but recently also you see him somebody
who the news reported on
him
fasting during the
being able to score at such a high level
what do you think if someone is not
who's not yet muslim muslim you know
when you see something like that what
are your thoughts impressions as far as
the ramadan the fasting and the islam
you know as somebody as i grow up i
really respect first of all i'm into
health and stuff and i understand the
you know health benefits to fasting
but i respect the discipline of of
muslims and i think that christians in
america uh they don't have the
discipline they had 50 60 years ago and
i think that's what's destroying you
know uh christian america is that the
discipline compared to old christians
like non-existent so you know muslims
the the uh the discipline to fast and
the health benefits of it and also the
you know subservience to god and the uh
the constant appreciation of it i i
think that's honorable and i uh yeah i
think i think it's it's definitely tough
to play at a high level like kyrie
because you know you're you're doing the
sports against the best people and he's
just he's doing great but i think his
soul and his spirit's in a great place
and you know he feel like he won he he
beat big pharma with the help of god and
the help of uh you know i guess just not
caving to the to the system i cannot
leave without giving you a gift if
you're not yet muslim and you're tuning
in to see what these muslims are talking
about and you'd like a free copy of the
quran go and visit the thedeenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the deen show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum